c'est une femelle rose qui n'a pas pondu
ses œufs mais certains d'entre eux ont
même du mal à atteindre leurs
frayères du tout il y a une très grande
inquiétude que les températures de l'eau dans
les rivières de l'île de Vancouver soient trop
chaudes
[Musique]
Osmo  molly Pitcher l'économie samoane
avec la technique Santander Viva Linda
Lopez zani avec de contas Simone Rena comme
résultat vous voyez / marquez le nevado expliquez
Malvika Missy lariviere cohosh en saison
chaque clip d'histoire Reba Jame Elna vous voyez
producteur le gant conséquence vous
voyez ici il devrait  être un très grand
étang, une sorte de petit lac tout
au long de ces feuilles de chou puant,
vous pouvez voir ces grandes feuilles sortir
ici du sol, il est complètement
asséché, vous pouvez voir le fond de la
rivière tout le long qui est très
inhabituel mais vous pouvez voir que ce sont des débris
du niveau de l'eau qui ont tellement baissé
2016 a été le niveau d'eau le plus bas
et la sécheresse la plus sèche de l'histoire enregistrée
et cette année est de soixante p  ercent pire
qu'en 2016 sur HC Davos est Zemus Pompey
Sontaran c'est OLP jhalak Paula Lehmann
absorbeurs de télévision un manifestant Navi
oncle Casa elegante voir
Cecily neva chien tu sais Parvati voir
lan-evo zéro
tu sais vaca-oom ya le taro soupe Genève
Zillow stockage de  l'eau dans le canapé du lac
et a été un gros problème, le
régime météorologique, en particulier en hiver,
change, ce qui a réduit la quantité d'
eau stockée dans le lac au
printemps et évidemment tout au long de l'
été, de sorte que le niveau du lac est plus
bas et  plus bas la plupart des années à l'automne
, donc le moment de la pluie d'automne est
vraiment important lorsque le saumon
revient pour récupérer l'eau dans la
rivière afin qu'il puisse migrer et squonk
s'il n'y a pas assez d'eau, le poisson
ne peut pas passer la température est  un problème avec
le
Louis généralement plus chaud qui affecte le
métabolisme du poisson il y a généralement
moins d'oxygène dissous et des eaux plus chaudes
sur Delhi Dilruba Sky News étant donné de
vida loca todav  ia
Anette Allah a révélé le grand koala Kumal
système révélé ne fera que faire chez les
souris normales stupide normalité pasilla le barrage
n'est pas maintenu la nourriture Halloween Evo
bleu Soleil vide à part sur la fiancée pour
calculer l'opéra toodaloo sumo complet
nous ne voyons aucun problème sur les plus détendus
encore  sur une semaine entière dans un livre vous vivez sur
les plages d'un moment le design la
chanson que nous voyons à un futur
logiciel différent la cellule solaire saumon Amaterasu
juste ici il y a peu de petits
alevins coho été une année très difficile pour
surtout beaucoup de Première  Les nations de la
côte qui ont dû fermer leurs
pêcheries alimentaires pour leurs communautés
mais aussi pour les pêcheurs commerciaux et
les pêcheurs sportifs et puis bien sûr
pour les ours et les loups et les
aigles et les oiseaux et les arbres toutes
les autres espèces  qui dépendent du saumon
pour tous ces écosystèmes qui
définissent la côte de la Colombie-Britannique
[Musique]
vous